举办了婚礼，
但是没有领证，
就上个月才结的婚，
然后这个月发现他对我现在是在想，
因为我们没有领证嘛，
我在想这个彩礼跟五金是全部返还给他，
还是就是打官司还是什么，
但这个事情我还没有告诉他爸妈。
一题的证据多吗？
证据足吗？
他说他是第一次，
我只发现了那个，
就是哎，
记录吗？
有认错书吗？
认错书悔过书有录音吗？
他自己承认他吗？
有，
好，
那他是干什么工作的？
嗯，
就是音乐行业，
模具行业的，
就是他不是吃公家饭的，
对吧，
对他本人的人设，
平时人设怎么样，
就是那样的，
他害不害怕他为这个事被亲戚朋友知道，
他害怕，
如果害怕的话，
就可以跟他谈了，
他给了多少彩礼，
20万左右吧，
20万左右，
五金是都值多少钱，
10多万，
现在你没有跟他谈分手的事情是吧，
我现在的想法就是。
因为我们暂时还没有领证，
本来是快要领证的，
然后发生了这么一档子事，
我就是在想，
因为还没有孩子嘛，
要不要就是。
到此为止，
要不然到此为止，
这件事情还是取决于你自己，
现在在跟他有亲密的行为的时候，
你能。
忍得了吗？
会有点抵触，
而且你在往后的岁月里面，
你可能还是会经常害怕担心，
比如说他晚上11点还没回来，
或者说他出差了，
他没有接你的电话，
没有接你的视频，
你可能会啊，
心里面还在想是不是又干嘛干嘛去了，
嗯，
对，
因为我自己原生家庭也不是很好嘛，
可能当初就想着尽快有个家，
因为之前在家父母也是老吵架，
我现在就感觉这边也不是我的家，
娘家也不是我的家，
就没有避风港嘛，
我现在我就不知道该怎么办，
因为他这个房子写的是她妈妈的名字，
然后车子是他的名字，
我现在就在想，
如果要原谅他的话，
我该走什么流程呢？
因为我不懂这些方面嘛，
我就是。
网上找那种，
我觉得啊，
我们想要找一个家，
就一定要找一个他自己活的很自洽的人姑娘。
就是说你老公这个人，
你想找一个男人啊，
男人他本身能幸福，
什么情况下的男人本身能幸福呢？
就是他自己活得很自洽，
很真实，
像你老公这种情况下，
第一这件事情，
如果他自己内心深处他接纳了自己，
那他就不会觉得PC这件事情有什么大不了，
他会将来还会提，
他现在衣服就是工资全给我，
就是说我们女人啊，
比如说你向往的婚姻生活是什么样子的，
如果向往的婚生活是谁，
这个男人不在外面乱搞的话，
那我们找的时候就要找一个，
他自己不在外面，
也不在外面乱搞，
他也很开心的，
从多中就开始谈恋爱了嘛，
谈了好多年了，
我们都才走上工作岗位没多久，
他就是周围的同事都是那种疲惫的人嘛，
然后当时我就已经有点他老是看那些擦边女嘛，
其实这些我都无所谓，
就是我当时也跟我爸爸沟通过，
我说如果他真的还是怎么怎么样，
我爸他就是意思，
男的都这样意思让我包容他，
我就感觉我自己的爸爸怎么是这样子的呢？
我现在就在想，
出了这么一档子事，
我要不要离开我现在在的这个城市，
去别的地方工作。
啊，
你自己是做什么工作的呢？
也是这个行业的，
那你自己的工作能力大概一年能挣多少钱呢？
那每个月六七千吧，
但是我感觉要是以我自己的能力买房很困难，
如果就是攒钱，
到最后就是为了买房，
背上房，
那自己最美好的青春年华都没有了，
你今年是多大，
而且我觉得你那么年轻，
然后你自己也有赚钱的能力啊，
人这一生啊，
就是幸福不幸福，
很多时候关键节点就这么一两步，
紧要处就这么一两步，
就你是否决定跟他领证，
可能对于你来说的话，
就是这紧要的关头了，
本来说是找个时间去领证的，
我现在是一点没有领的想法了，
但是我觉得我现在这个事情我在想要不要跟他爸妈说，
因为他妈妈对我还是挺好的，
不说，
你不说，
你才有可能争取到更多的利益，
你如果把这事儿摊开了，
这事已经不惧怕别人知道了，
你争取不到更多的利益，
我假设啊，
如果我不说，
我就跟他和平分手，
和平分手我退你一半，
我退你10万块钱，
我也仁至义尽了，
但是你对我也造成了，
比如说我们已经订过婚了，
已经办过婚礼了，
我也算是二婚了，
对我也造成伤害了，
但是。
剩下的钱我就不退给你了啊，
那一头自知理亏，
有把柄在你手上，
有证据在你手上，
他也不好说什么，
所以你就能争取到一部分的利益，
但如果你把这事儿捅破了，
他已经不怕了，
那他去打官司去告你的话，
那你可能基本上都得退。
他现在的意思是不想再光志全给我就是认罪，
哪怕就是走一系列流程，
什么忏悔书，
认证书，
什么协议什么东西的，
他都愿意弄，
但是我现在就是过不去，
那事情我也没有跟我爸妈讲，
就是任何人都没有说，
我就现在不知道该怎么办，
就是到底分手还是原谅他，
首先肯定不能在这个阶段去匆忙的去领那个证的，
对吧？
其次的话，
你如果你不能接受的话，
不要勉强自己，
姑娘你还很年轻，
你才25岁，
人生的路还很长，
你这刚结婚都没有生小孩，
那我自己的原生家庭你也很差嘛，
我以后可能就是这个关系结束的话，
我以后要再谈这个男生还是这样，
或者人家并不能接接受我的原生家庭，
我就。
很为难，
如果原生家庭差，
就先学会一件事情，
跟我的原生家庭去做切割，
要成为那个嗯，
在恶性循环的原生家庭当中剪断那个恶性循环的人，
我要拿一把剪刀剪断这种恶，
这个呃，
不好的原生家庭对我带来的负面的影响。
如果你自己有能力赚啊，
6000块钱7000块钱的话，
就逃离这样的原生家庭，
去到离得远一点的城市，
那我每个月要给我父母钱嘛，
因为我也是这样想的，
我一直想到一个陌生的城市，
但我在想这样会不会不孝顺，
毕竟我爸妈从小把我养到那么大，
如果你爸妈现在还没有老到那种吃不上饭，
没有老到那种生活不能自理，
他们自己还有赚钱的能力的话，
你大可不必，
你现在顾好你自己，
如你手上有个30万、
50万的存款的话，
你的生活的那种安全系数，
幸福指数会大不一样，
你在选择工作的时候，
选择伴侣的时候，
你会从容很多，
你在面对自己有成长的机会，
有很好的学习的机会，
或者说跟人家一起创业的机会的时候，
你会勇敢很多。
还有一个问题就是律师，
嗯，
那现在这个情况，
我就是该你联系哪方面去就证明。
他有这个自己写悔过书就可以了，
这个也是有法律效应的是吗？
其实他起到的就是震慑的作用，
就是让你的这个男朋友，
他有把柄在你手上，
自己的悔过书不就是一个把柄嘛，
就是一个证据吗，
在你手上，
然后他就不好意思跟你撕破脸呀，
因为他跟你撕破脸了之后，
所有的亲戚朋友，
爸爸妈都得知道他这个事儿啊，
其实起到的是这个作用，
知道了吧，
有的时候就是爸爸妈妈关系不好，
爸爸妈妈老吵架，
孩子慢慢的他就会停止爱自己，
就是像我觉得刚才这个姑娘的话，
你现在需要做的人生的第一课是脱离爸爸妈妈，
从那样的原生家庭里面逃离出去，
学会爱自己，
学会自己给自己安全感，
自己给自己攒一笔钱的话，
你遇到好的学习机会，
你才可以，
比如说现在这个工作干到不开心，
好有一个好的学习深造的机会，
我才可以去参加一下培训，
因为我手上有十万20万的存款，
我不用担心这个月交不上房租，
不用担心下个月吃不上饭，
你只有在更好的环境，
更积极向上的那样的氛围里面去找到的伴侣，
当自己的生命状态是积极的、
健康的，
是奔着好日子去的。
你在这样的状态下，
你。
遇到的伴侣，
找到的伴侣才有可能是那个给你带来正向互动的，
他也是积极的，
他也是啊，
奔着要过好日子的，
也是想要提升自己的，
然后才有可能找到那样的合适的伴侣，
剪断这样一个恶性的不好的原生家庭，
否则的话，
像你这个状态，
如果你嫁给了现在这个男朋友，
他又有这样的行为，
你对她的信任感又在一点一点的磨没，
然后你们两个人再生个小孩出来的话，
其实你们在创造一个更加不幸福的灵魂，
创造一个更加不幸福的原生家庭，
也不幸福的这样一个生命体，
那你就进入了一个恶性循环当中，
能理解吗？
生命有的时候就是一个一个的轮回，
当我们看明白这个轮回的齿轮了之后，
我们看明白了之后，
我们自己就要做那个剪断这个轮回的人。
从我这里，
我们新开启一轮。
好的，
轮回。